i do want to introduce some good news
because that's important people need
good news right now don't you absolutely
yeah and you may not have heard about
this but
best buy has a new membership program
check it out for 200 a year you get
perks like unlimited tech support and
free shipping
isn't that cool yeah yeah it's been so
successful other retail companies are
trying the same thing
for example for ten dollars a month home
depot
will tell you where their in-store
employees are hiding
not bad that's probably worth it that's
helpful yeah 10 bucks and they're like
oh he's back there in the break room
for 25 burger king will let you take the
king costume home for the night
no questions asked yeah
for fifty dollars a month whole foods
will tell you which cantaloupes are
sweet
and which are just giant orange
cucumbers
for just one annual payment of ten
thousand dollars h
r block will do your taxes the rich
person way
for 20 and a pack of winston's steinmart
will tell you
why it's called that
that that is worth it yeah yeah i want
to know
i want to know hey if you join their
frequent flyer club
spirit airlines will upgrade you to
another airline
oh oh wow and finally for an extra 30
a week amazon will pay its workers an
extra
30 a week i think this is very nice
yeah those are all good good systems
good systems yes